the common misconception I think most
people have with sports nutrition is
that you can eat anything and just as
long as you get the calories you're
gonna be fine
but the quality that you put in is is
just as important and if you put good
stuff in your body during training
you're gonna get good stuff out of your
body I think a major turning point for
me a nutrition strategy was when I
realized I needed to take a gel during a
10k run coming off of a hard 40k bike
and then tried to put your body through
a hard 35 minute run was probably more
than I could take on one or two gels so
being able to use the science in sport
gel while I'm running and have something
that I don't need water for really was a
turning point for my nutrition I was
introduced to Sciences for last year in
August and I started training with it
and I instantly I was like this is what
I've been looking for because a lot of
times you need to always follow a gel
with water the sense of sport it's more
liquidy so it's really easy to get down
and you don't need water I like to
practice similar nutrition habits for
both training and racing I find that
using science and sport gels in hard
workouts just gets my body prepared to
absorb the nutrition in races I think
timing of fuel is the most important
thing for anyone getting into the sport
triathlon or even at the top end making
sure you're fueled properly with your
gels and bars to get the best out of
yourself because then that's when you
improve the most
you